[Music]
and responsible Fitness News submitted
by Ling long there's a new fitness trend
called plugging that keeps both humans
and Mother Earth healthy so if you guys
haven't heard this new thing is plugging
where you pretty much jog and you pick
up trash on the way so it's a
portmanteau or like a combination of two
words jogging and pluck up up which
pluck up is Swedish for pick up
oh that's when you like put your finger
in your butthole and then you shoot
boogers out of your nose I'm saying
Peggy
it sounds like Peggy Peggy hanging this
one make sure your [ __ ] off Peggy's
when a chick puts a strap on and then
[ __ ] the guy in a bottle you know I
don't like watching that I don't I
watched it and I was like so soft and
creamy guys a lot of people a lot of men
like that my hooker friend gets paid to
do that oh maybe maybe when I'm older
I'll like it not to [ __ ] guys are the
guys like I'm gonna [ __ ] this guy's to
get paid for it
[ __ ] like middle-aged straight men no I
would be down cuz it's a sign of
dominance like now you're my [ __ ]
[ __ ] you wear a strap-on yeah get ready
for some football bar but never want to
get paid Never Say Never
cuz when you're 50 years old your balls
gonna be loose and you might like it cuz
I heard that there's a male g-spot up in
there because my friend yeah yeah well
he his roommate tell us more yeah she's
a stripper and in she was you know she
was saying how her boyfriend likes
getting fingered in the booty hole watch
a lot of guys a lot of guys like that
but like a full-on like bill art loves
that I'm just kidding I mean as soon as
that finger goes here and then you
tighten up yeah I like the pressing but
as soon as it goes in I go oh leave me
alone you know over the weekend I went
to a baby shower and one of the baby
shower games was to have a balloon in
between you and a partner or you know
pop it yeah and you have to like hum to
pop it right and so
was I partnered up with this little girl
and so she we couldn't get our balloon
to pop event so she was going first but
then when I went and I was doing that I
could see what you're saying with the
whole dominat thing like Oh started
feeling like you put it on the girl's
back you don't face each other Oh like
making a baby that's [ __ ] aroud II I
don't get what the point of a baby
shower game for that is that no anyway
here clogging is healthy for the
environment and healthy for you cuz
you're jogging all right well now for
that I like that is pretty cool but I'm
gonna tell you something that's gonna
make you think I'm an honorable man when
I go to the dog park and I pick up my
dog [ __ ] I also pick up other dogs we
did too
because I'm like you [ __ ] dirty
people how dare you leave dog [ __ ] here
this is my playground [ __ ] if
there's a lot of [ __ ] and those people
are gonna take away our privileges I'm
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] so we pick
it up after well I was in a k-town
mm-hmm the spot that I was at before
right in front of this patch of grass
and nobody and I nobody would pick up
their dog [ __ ] yeah so it turned out it
wasn't a nobody it was one specific
[ __ ] person and it was our [ __ ]
neighbor that's always did it yep every
time and so like I I didn't notice it
until my landlord told me that it was
the neighbor and so he put out a sign
saying hey pick up your dog she wouldn't
do it and then he was she's like such a
nice guy on there heaven I'm not a nice
guy no you're not so like I'm literally
looking up through the window through my
brother's room and I see their dog
[ __ ] and they're about to walk I'm
like oh God
and they went and they did it again the
next day saw them they picked the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up oh good for you
shame shame shame shame because it
wasn't is collected at all and it is
left in his front door yeah that's how
you know what the sad [ __ ] is - it's not
even like a chihuahua they have like two
[ __ ] pitbulls so they're huge you
know what I mean that's a human size
[ __ ] yes I'm saying yeah see you gotta
[ __ ] collect that Shane is leaving
out their doormat it's nothing you're
doing that's what I'm saying dude and
then let them see you and then you just
go Platt and then look in smashes ya
under windshield I don't know why people
do that but sometimes I think if you're
at a dog park the doggie just goes and
you're not looking
and it happens oh yeah oh yeah sometimes
so it's okay so this trend started in
Sweden and there were some people that
are saying like yeah you know I've come
across so much trash since I started
plugging and then this one ladies good
luck in LA disgusting thing and like she
finds a ton of fold diapers no just on
the floor Wow come on
why pants are [ __ ] weird sometimes
doesn't [ __ ] ask parents out there like
tailor changing their babies [ __ ]
diapers on a restaurant table that [ __ ]
pisses me off why are people so
literally I hate that when I see people
like at a stop we're just in their car
and they start throwing trash I'm like
hello this is your [ __ ] bike city
like you're gonna get caught up in all
this [ __ ] you don't see that in Hawaii
though you see how because over the
respect I know I know
only the tourists come here and [ __ ]
crap that stuff Japan - dude I will say
this though - Pat what they teach that
at the very baby age the first second
year or something like that the first
few years in school like first or second
grade you're just learning etiquette so
you clean the school you make your own
lodge you pretty much have to take care
of your own area that's time and then
they give you tests and stuff like that
like maybe third grader on or whatever
you know is interesting cuz we're in
Hawaii
I feel really bad like I'll never ever
let her but then when I step in LA I
look at her out of like you're like
between the McDonald's rapper now you
know what though there's a study of
trash and filthy cities right like
there's this guy in India that was
wondering why there's so much litter in
India he's an Indian guy and then they
took this corner that there was a huge
mountain of trash and he was like once
there's a little bit of trash people
will just add to it but then they clean
it all out they painted it nicely and
then they made sure that someone came in
like cleaned up trash and eventually
that place was never trashed again
that's how it is with your [ __ ] stink
like if there's one I give this
is clean it remains clean but then Essen
is one person like Hika dirty dirty like
cup or something then that just starts
piling up you need to talk to be little
about that [ __ ] I saw that fool you
were just like getting worse cuz it
twice already this week I had to swerve
around all these clothes and all this
trash in the middle of the freeway
I'm like all that puppet I think that
fell out of a car no it looked like no
cuz it was like a cart to homeless
persons but they're just dumping it in
front the trash that I throw the way I
throw away on the street by the way you
can't justify it's like straw wrappers
that's horrible that's the truth it's
paper if this is white have you seen
what happens when you scrunch them up
and they turn into a snake yeah that's
fun you provide an entertainment to all
the little bugs on the ground and they
disintegrate really fast no you can't
justify a litter bug the only letter I
can I can feel okay with the littering
is like orange peels or like actual no
it's biodegradable bro so was the
[ __ ] paper though after like why are
you but why do you feel like you have to
defend yourself you shouldn't left it
there you're obviously feeling guilty so
stop it well why don't you stop putting
up and I feel guilty [ __ ] how about we
talk about that when I do that really
runs and like Spartan runs and stuff
that's what pisses me off the most
because it's like this place is
basically renting out the place like
whether it's a farm or whether it's like
a ski slope or something right and in
this event is held for the Spartans or
the racers and when you're running
through and you see all this [ __ ]
trash I'm thinking will they let us do
this again cleanup crews for that
specifically right because they have
yeah but even then they create so much
trash in the first place I'm like man
that's ungrateful I'm very proud at
raves when we're done when we're done
dancing there's like you what we'd like
to do is when everyone leaves we go out
in the field like where the Colosseum
was I'm gas wallets drugs key
use credit cards like everything on the
ground I want to do that who was the one
that blatantly throws out banana peels
out the window was [ __ ] Mario Kart
one I thought it was one of us but I
know somebody spit on me I don't let her
not us who the [ __ ] was it but then I
was like so appalled I was in the car
and they an entire orange split I was
like yo what the [ __ ] and they're like
it was back to the earth that's all they
say was back it wasn't one of you guys
know it sounds like something I would
say no I have black banana peels on my
driver's side it smells after a while it
smells great cuz I do but it's hard and
black it turns into a banana peel jerk
no they just rot it just cuz I don't
that's how much I don't like the litter
so I just have like bottles and trash in
my driver's license all that personal
responsibility personal responsibility I
give back to nature or my pubic hairs
all right we don't do that anymore do we
not anymore vices shave might be here in
the backyard or let the birds take your
fun of nests cuz I have to clean up in
the backyard so I just shaved my pubes
and even on the ground and the birds
coming together for the day
have you seen the births actually I know
they're looking for how did you figure
this out like what came so you I found
out that birds use a lot of different
materials with a nest like dog hair for
weeds whatever and all that well I might
as well do them a favor and shave in the
backyard so they can take the curly
hairs hey Lisa
saw for the babies hey you can't just
sit there off some weird [ __ ] the beggar
I should like you do shave it appears
I'm not well can I go in the backyard
please look I I can't forget it like
okay I just want to shave in the back
cuz it because it's cleaner that way not
to clean but the fact that it extends to
it's for the birds and their birth
mutual though it's one I don't have to
clean the bathroom okay wait let's look
so have you seen the birds actually use
them are you just assuming I tried
really hard not to disrupt it because
you know I just figure this guy doing
going into a [ __ ] pet store right he
just goes to a pet store he goes to his
pad something if I look into the cage
and I see a full-on nest I leave him
alone but if I see that the building
that I got covered in pubic you just so
upset you can't even get it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]